>> Sean: THE GREAT ONE MARK
LAVIN ON FIRE WARNING WITH THE
DEEP STATE AND THE BATTLE
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FBI SOUGHT TO INTERFERE
IN THE ELECTION I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE TOP ECHELON.
THEY SOUGHT TO INTERFERE WITH
OUR ELECTION AND IN OUR ELECTION
IN WORSE WAYS THAN THE RUSSIANS
DOES.
HOW DID BARACK OBAMA IS NEVER
QUESTIONED ABOUT THIS.
HIS NAME NEVER COMES UP.
NEVER COMES UP.
ARE YOU TELLING ME THE DIRECTOR
OF THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
SUSAN RICE DIDN'T KNOW A THING
AND BEN RHODES, A WELL KNOWN
LEAKER, HE DIDN'T KNOW A THING
AND VALERIE JARRET CONTROLLING
EVERY CABINET AND SECRETARY AND
JAMES COMEY WHO LIKES TO MEET
WITH PRESIDENTS AND TAKES MEMOS
DIDN'T MEET WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND WRITE MEMOS?
IT'S NICE TO SEE WE HAVE
COMMITTEES IN CONGRESS CONCERNED
AND WE HAVE RADIO HOSTS
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
IT'S A NICE TO SEE WE HAVE
TELEVISION HOSTS CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS.
WHERE THE HELL WERE THEY IN
MARCH?
MARK WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
WHERE WERE THEY IN MARCH WHEN I
HAD INFORMATION, PULLED IT
TOGETHER THE PUBLIC ACCOUNTS AND
BEGAN TO PULL THE STRINGS AND TO
SEE SOMETHING DIDN'T SMELL
RIGHT.
SOMETHING DIDN'T LOOK RIGHT.
AND THE MEDIA CAME DOWN ON ME
LIKE A TON OF BRICKS.
>> Sean: AND MARK WAS ON THE
SHOW AT THAT TIME AND SARA
ABUSE AND A WARRANT AT TRUMP
TOWER.
HERE WITH REACTION, HARVARD
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
PROFESSORIALAN DER SHOW WITS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
YOU FEAR THEY'RE GOING TO TRY
AND GO AFTER OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
COLLUSION.
>> WELL, MY WORRY IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS COULD BE
STARTED IF MUELLER STARTS
PROBING THE PRESIDENT'S MOTIVES
AS TO WHY HE EXERCISED HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO WHY
HE FIRED COMEY AND TELLING
COMEYY,
MOTIVES AND GET IN THE BRAIN OF
WINEBERGER.
NOBODY THOUGHT THOUGHT TO PROBE
HIS MIND OR THE WORKINGS OF HIS
MIND.
I THINK ONE POSSIBILITY IS FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO SAY, LOOK, IKE
-- I'LL ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
ALLEGED CRIMINAL CONDUCT BUT NOT
MOTIVE
MOTIV
THAT WE'LL GET THAT RESOLVED IN
THE SUPREME COURT BEFORE ANYBODY
JUSTICE OR EXERCISING
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
>> Sean: WHY IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT, PROFESSOR, WOULD
THE PRESIDENT EVER GO BEFORE
MUELLER KNOWING ABOUT COMEY AND
SPECIAL COUNCIL CAN SUBPOENA
HIM.
HE CAN REFUSE TO ANSWER SPECIAL
HAS TO COMPLY WITH THE SUBPOENA
IN FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY.
HE'LL PROBABLY HAVE TO
COMPROMISE AND WORK OUT A DEAL
WITH TIME LIMITS AND HIS LAWYER
PRESENT AND LIMITS ON THE SCOPE
OF THE QUESTIONING.
NOW, THEY WON'T AGREE ON
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
MUELLER WILL INSIST ON ANSWERING
IT WILL CREATE A SEPARATION OF
POWERS FOR ANYONE TO QUESTION
NOBODY HAS THE ABILITY TO
QUESTION THE PRESIDENT'S
WELL-KNOWN CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR,
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF A, AN FBI
DIRECTOR AND INVESTIGATOR RIDING
EXONERATION DRAFT AFTER DRAFT,
MONTHS BEFORE THEY INTERVIEW THE
KEY PEOPLE INVOLVED?
B, WHEN A PHONY DOSSIER PAID FOR
BY ONE CANDIDATE TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEN BASED
ON A FISA WARRANT ISN'T THERE A
STRONG ARGUMENT THIS NEVER
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED?
>> YES AND EVERY CIVIL
LIBERTARIANS SHOULD BE CONCERNED
WITH THE POTENTIAL ABUSES OF
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
COMMISSION.
NOT A POLITICAL INQUIRY, TO
INQUIRE INTO WHETHER THERE WAS
INFLUENCE IN THE ELECTION BY
GET IT WHEN THERE'S PARTISAN
DISPUTES BY SPECIAL COUNCIL
WHOSE ONLY PROPER JOB IS TO
INVESTIGATE SPECIAL CRIMES.
>> Sean: TO USE ONE CANDIDATE, A
PHONY DOSSIER THEY PAID FOR TO
BE THE PREMISE OF A FISA WARRANT
AGAINST AN OPPOSITION CANDIDATE
AND THEN AN INCOMING PRESIDENT
I BELIEVE THERE WERE CRIMES
COMMITTED.
MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, DESTRUCTION OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
I DON'T KNOW MANY PEOPLE THAT
ACID WASH THEIR HARD DRIVES AND
BEAT THE [BLEEP] OUT OF THEIR
INVESTIGATED.
>> AS YOU KNOW --
>> Sean: MY QUESTION HERE IS,
THERE HAS TO BE A BASIS HERE
>> LOOK, THERE ARE TWO ISSUES.
I AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY THAT
IF THE FISA WARRANT WAS BASED ON
A QUESTIONABLE AND POSSIBLY
FALSE SERIES OF DOCUMENTS, THAT
UNDER THE SUPREME COURT DOCTRINE
CAN BE CHALLENGE.
THE ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOU EXONERATE BEFORE AN
INVESTIGATION DEPENDS IF THERE'S
A CRIME CHARGE.
IF THERE'S NO CRIME OF COURSE